à mon niveau benjamin prend la route
avec christophe le chef pour mieux
comprendre son attachement à la région
auquel christophe moment de voir un
producteur de caviar saint viâtre en
plein coeur de la sologne
tu vas voir y'a que des étangs des bois
et et la nature ils partent à la
rencontre de vincent hennequart l'unique
producteur de caviar de la région il
produit du caviar depuis plus de dix ans
bonjour j'ai du courage mais on voulait
montrer un petit peu à benjamin
justement ben voilà la philosophie et
cette richesse il convient pas au revoir
dans la région avec avec les esturgeons
ailleurs les esturgeons sont les
poissons qui produisent le caviar et
chez vincent leur élevage dure en
moyenne 9 ans la manipulation est en
train de faire c'est qu'on reprend des
femelles qui sont matures donc qui porte
du caviar qui ensuite vont aller passer
un séjour de quatre semaines en eau
claire avant quand elle passe au
laboratoire où elles donneront
effectivement leur camion est donc la
dernière étape du coup c'est juste finir
voilà là on va finir de poitiers et puis
et on va voir surgir le goût du caviar
ne provient pas de son lieu d'élevage
mais de l' espèce d'esturgeon et il en
existe 27 dans le monde selon les
espèces
il faut entre 7 et 20 ans la femelle
esturgeons pour produire jusqu'à un kilo
de ces oeufs au goût unique est toujours
en fonction de cette espèce le prix du
kilo varie de 1000 à 37000 euros
déguster ce mets d'exception c'est faire
un plongeon dans l'époque des dinosaures
à l'esturgeon est en effet un poisson
préhistorique
aujourd'hui la france avec ses 35 tonnes
annuelles est devenu le troisième
producteur mondial de caviar derrière
la chine et l'italie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là on commence déjà bien bien les voir
vite choisi son petit ses impressions
ouais c'est ok je voyais ça plus petits
j'avoue moi l'après-midi en règle
générale je vais voir un producteur
c'est vraiment mon truc et pour moi
c'est source d'inspiration c'est prendre
l'air vincent je le vois une fois tous
les quinze jours place à la dégustation
tenue de rigueur exigées pour entrer
dans le laboratoire aller chercher dans
la réserve ça vincent c'est quelque
chose que tu fais toi régulièrement
justement d'ouvrir des boîtes et de
goûter ou oui ça c'est le suivi qui est
obligatoire de loin des produits parce
qu'en fin de compte on fait des
sélections des tests et puis pendant le
la production s'aperçoit qu'à kamiar
qu'on ait diamètre règles de base pour
un bon caviar la taille de l'oeuf 2,8 mm
de diamètre minimum vous allez pouvoir
goûter donc un caviar qui a un mois et
un caviar qu'il ya deux jours on dirait
presque des lentilles en fait je pense
que c'était beaucoup plus petit premier
premiers tests jeux super bon je pensais
pas qu'on sentait autant le justement
l'aspect beurré en fait on le sent on
sombre un petit plaisir à 2000 euros le
kilo
bon verdict j'avais un petit peu d'à
priori je pensais que ça avait un goût
très très amer en fait c'est super bon
vraiment alors je pense que j'en
mangerai pas tous les jours parce que on
a parlé un petit peu pris c'est
clairement pas dans mes moyens mais
c'est une très très belle découverte sur
des métiers que j'imaginais vraiment pas
mais voilà